I think this is a really best
opportunity for her
you should not care about the overall
result not be afraid of anyone
strong tournaments will have her to
improve her chest levels
I'm just hoping to do well but try not
to keep my expectations to having no
we're just gonna go back to the game of
Karissa because this is such an
incredible moment all eyes are on
Karissa now and actually you're right
yes because before the tournament
Karissa tweeted at critic Chad that she
was really excited to play in the
Karin's Cup and particularly to face the
world champion exactly what are we
expecting King anywhere wins I say what
are we expecting what's very romantic
because once the Queen and they came
join each other the day after
Valentine's Day it's gonna be brutal to
defend takes two six already it's 86 now
we have Queen f2 she'll Chuck covering
that Keith wheeler
Queen King h1 you were about to say she
but I think Queen f1 King h2 Queen h3
mg1 Queen g3 takes text you from old
Chuck mate mmm-hmm
that is so simple so right yeah that's
what you'll do yeah energy has a cute
okay she did it the other way three to
start yeah and when the King goes did
you want and you play the Queen trade
the Queen trade we're both making Queens
there it is Queen g3 Andrew when June
will probably resign yes I think she's
gonna resign what a beautiful finish
what look at that technique there it is
it Karissa yeah
the Women's World Championship and June
knocking - in June out of almost all
contention for the character she has a
mathematical chance it's the dream you
know you play the number one seed in the
tournament the world champion
everybody's watching you and you play
the best game of your career